und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
blickt man auf das Kriegsgeschehen in
der Ukraine ergibt sich ein gemischtes
Bild einerseits vermeldet die Ukraine
militärische Erfolge etwa dass sie
letzte Nacht wieder ein großes
russisches Munitionslager an die Luft
gesprengt habe
Militärexperten vermuten dass solche
Schläge auch dank westlicher
Präzisionswaffen gelingen die unter
anderem die USA geliefert haben zugleich
machen aber auch die Russen weiter
bodengewinne im Donbass und verstärken
den Beschuss auf Großstädte wie rakev
von dort berichtet daran Hassan ZD
war eine pulsierende Stadt vor dem Krieg
die Wunden des Krieges überall sichtbar
kaum vernarbt und täglich kommen neue
Einschläge hinzu
160.000 Studenten zählte die Universität
inzwischen ist auch sie in Teilen
zerstört es gibt keine Vorlesungen mehr
viele Studenten dienen an der Front
andere sind geflüchtet
Victoria blieb doch ihr Doktor Titel ist
in weite Ferne gerückt durch den Krieg
ich meine wissenschaftlichen Ambitionen
noch ich hatte meine Doktorarbeit
begonnen und natürlich hatte ich dafür
aufwendige Feldstudien durchgeführt der
Krieg hat alles gestoppt und ich muss
wieder ganz von vorne beginnen auch
hatte ich eine große Reise geplant nach
der Promotion diese Träume sind durch
den Krieg einfach nur geplatzt aber
jetzt habe ich andere Werte
abbauen
zwei von drei Einwohnern haben Haki
verlassen trotz Krieg und Beschuss der
Nahverkehr funktioniert wieder und ist
kostenlos gefüllt sind die Busse aber
vor allem weil sie so selten fahren ja
ich bin hier seit dem 24 Februar es war
zwischenzeitlich mal viel ruhiger wenn
alle evakuiert waren und dann sind viele
zurückgekehrt jetzt sind wir eine Art
lebendes Schutzschild der Basar in
krakev er war einmal der größte der
Ukraine waren aus Russland dem Kaukasus
und Zentralasien wurden hier
umgeschlagen bis er im März völlig
zerstört wurde
julia sah als die russischen Raketen
einschlugen dieser Laden gehörte einem
Geschäftsfreund aus Aserbaidschan er
verlor waren in Wert von einer halben
Millionen Euro aber nicht sein Leben
businessi hier natürlich wollen wir die
wieder aufbauen
uns jeden Tag es ist äußerst brutal
es ist hier alles sehr hart wenn der
Luft Alarm deaktiviert ist meist erst am
Nachmittag keimt ziviles Leben auf am
LED sprüht Graffiti seine Kunst
schmückte die Mauern kakis bereits vor
der russischen Invasion er ist
entschlossen trotz der Angriffe hier zu
bleiben
ob er zurückkommt oder nicht ob sie im
Westen der Ukraine bleiben oder im
Ausland aber wir hier wir müssen das
neue Leben aufbauen
sein jüngstes Werk die Grundstruktur hat
ein Artillerie Geschoss gelegt er konnte
darin die Form einer Blume entdecken
und dann schalten wir noch live nach
harkev zu Dara hasansa D Lara du musst
deswegen Luftalarm in den Parkhaus gehen
bis uns von dort aus jetzt zugeschaltet
Shark ist das ist ja die zweitgrößte
Stadt der Ukraine glaubt man denn dort
dass die Russen ernsthaft versuchen
wollen diese Millionenstadt einzunehmen
nein die Menschen hier glauben das in
der Tat nicht es ist ein großer
Unterschied zu dem Bombardierung im März
denn diesmal ist hakif im Umland
gesichert durch schwere
Verteidigungslinien und durch eine große
mannstarke Einheit die Rakel schützt
doch die russische Artillerie in den
letzten zwei Tagen überschießt diese
Stellung und trifft vor allem auch
Wohngebiete und das verstehen die
Menschen hier in keiner Weise denn die
Stellung liegen ja vor der Stadt von der
russischen Armee von der ukrainischen
Armee sie empfinden es hier wirklich als
Terrorismus
und hat die Ukraine ja ihrerseits eine
Offensive im Süden angekündigt
ja und die wird auch vorbereitet sie
wurde schon vor längerer Zeit durch
evakuierungswarnungen vorbereitet und es
werden auch immer mehr schwere Waffen in
den Süden gebracht es werden Soldaten
dorthin verlegt und die Gefechte gehen
los mit gezielten Schüssen auf dem
Munitionsdepots das könnte darauf
hindeuten dass das erste Ziel vielleicht
die Stadt Carson ist denn diese liegt
westlich vom kniepro Fluss und ist damit
auch für die Russen schwerer zu
versorgen aber die genauen Strategien
wissen natürlich nur die Militärs im
Generalstab
daran danke dir viele Grüße nach
zu den Ländern die Russland unterstützen
gehört Iran nach US-Angaben ist Iran
unter anderem bereit Russland hunderte
Drohnen für den Kriegseinsatz zu liefern
verwundern tut das nicht Moskau und
Teheran haben gemeinsame Interessen
speziell in Syrien wobei sie Diktator
Assad unterstützen und ganz generell in
ihrer Gegnerschaft zu den USA und dem
Westen dazu passt die Meldung dass Iran
nun die baldige Hinrichtung des
iranisch-schwedischen physikersjalali
geplant hat er sitzt seit 2016 in
Teheran in Haft im berüchtigten
eventgefängnis der Fall hat die
Beziehungen zwischen Schweden und Iran
schwer belastet Jalali gilt als
politische Geisel kameran safiarian
berichtet
die Minute mit der Hinrichtung ihres
Mannes rechnen wie Dome heronia ihr Mann
der iranisch-schwedische Wissenschaftler
Ahmad Resort jaloi wartet den Tehran auf
die Vollstreckung im Mai wurde die
Hinrichtung in letzter Minute
aufgeschoben wir treffen wieder in
Stockholm seit zwei Jahren kann sie nur
über seine Familie Kontakt zu ihm
aufnehmen
Folter für ihn da er weiß dass man ihn
in wenigen Tagen hinrichten will er
sitzt häufig die ganze Nacht da weil er
Angst hat dass man ihn gleich abholt er
kann seit sechs Jahren nicht mehr
richtig schlafen
Fotos ihres Mannes aus guten Zeiten
jetzt ist er gezeichnet von monatelanger
Einzelhaft und Folter
hier am renommierten carolinska-institut
in Stockholm hat Jalali gearbeitet auf
Konferenzen lernt er auch iranische
Atomwissenschaftler kennen das wird ihm
zum Verhängnis 2016 lädt man ihn zu
einem Vortrag in den Iran ein und
verhaftet ihn er soll Informationen über
iranische Atomwissenschaftler in Israel
verraten haben das gibt Jalali im
Staatsfernsehen zu
quinette man hat ihn gezwungen ein
Geständnis abzulegen im Film montiert
das Regime Bilder meines Mannes mit
seinen italienischen Arztkollegen und
behauptet es sein israelische Spione
sehen sie vor seiner Festnahme hat man
ihn gefragt ob er für Iran spionieren
könnte er hat abgelehnt gesagt er sei
nur ein Wissenschaftler
das könnte sein Todesurteil gewesen sein
seine Frau ist in ständigen Kontakt mit
den Anwälten ihres Mannes in Iran
journalis Chef am carolinska-institut
spricht von einem Angriff auf die
akademische Freiheit
das wird unmöglich sein dass der Iran
weiter ein Partner in der
internationalen akademischen Community
bleibt falls dieses Urteil vollstreckt
wird
Teheran ist isoliert es will westliche
Sanktionen loswerden doch das
atomabkommen droht zu scheitern dennoch
provoziert Iran mit der Exekution des
schwedisch iranischen Wissenschaftlers
Jalali falls in Schweden der iranische
Agent Hamid Nuri am 14 Juli wegen
Kriegsverbrechen verurteilt wird
[Musik]
es ist ja mittlerweile schon lange her
dass die Iraner begonnen haben
unschuldige westliche Staatsbürger in
Iran zu inhaftieren um damit Terroristen
oder auch Agenten aus Deutschland aus
Belgien aus Schweden oder aus anderen
Ländern frei zu pressen immer wieder hat
wieder merania beim schwedischen
Außenministerium auf das Schicksal ihres
Mannes hingewiesen ohne Erfolg auch
unsere Anfrage bleibt unbeantwortet
das Leben eines Mannes ist in großer
Gefahr ich fordere die schwedische
Regierung und die EU auf alles zu tun
damit man Mann wieder zu uns
zurückkehren kann
ein Spielball der Machtpolitik der
Mullahs in Teheran
jetzt nachts Wolf weiter mit den
Nachrichten da geht es zunächst ums
Thema Gasversorgung ja und um die
Diskussion wer im Fall einer
ganzknappheit bevorzugt beliefert wurde
eine EU-Verordnung gibt kritischer
Infrastruktur wie Krankenhäusern und
privaten Haushalten einen Vorrang
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck weist auch
auf die Folgen einer langfristigen
Unterbrechung von industrieller
Produktion hin
niemand soll frieren aber das private
Haushalte auch in Anteil leisten und das
eine dauerhafte oder langfristige
Unterbrechung von industrieller
Produktion massive Folgen auch für die
Gesamtwirtschaft hat für die Menschen im
Land für die Versorgung Situation das
denke ich ist inzwischen auch erkannt
bundesinnenministerin Felser will das
Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der
Informationstechnik BSI zur
Zentralstelle für den Kampf gegen
Cyber-Attacken auf Ziele in Deutschland
machen Feser sagte in Berlin aktuell
liegen die Verantwortung hier noch bei
den Ländern das BSI könne bislang nur
Amtshilfe leisten das reiche nicht sie
kündigte einen Vorschlag für eine
entsprechende Grundgesetzänderung an
wir im kommenden Jahr nach Kroatien
reist kann offiziell mit Euro bezahlen
damit es Kroatien das erste Land das
seit 2015 den Euro einführt die
EU-Finanzminister besiedelten formell
die Aufnahme des Landes in die
Gemeinschaftswährung und legten den
Umtauschkurs fest die Tourismusbranche
befürwortet die Euroeinführung andere
befürchten durch die Umstellung
steigende Lebenshaltungskosten
in Japan haben tausende Menschen von
Ex-Ministerpräsident aber Abschied
genommen die Trauernden hatten sich an
den Straßenrändern versammelt als der
Wagen mit dem Sarg des Politikers durch
das Zentrum Tokios fuhr zuvor hatte es
eine Trauerfeier in privatem Kreis
gegeben aber war am Freitag bei einem
Wahlkampfauftritt niedergeschossen
worden
der UN-Sicherheitsrat hat doch noch
einen Kompromiss beschlossen für weitere
Hilfslieferungen in den Nordwesten
Syriens mit der Resolution bleibt der
Zugang dort für weitere sechs Monate
offen diesen Zeitraum hatte Russland
vorgeschlagen die westlichen Länder
hatten eine Verlängerung um ein Jahr
gefordert vor allem zur
Planungssicherheit für die
Hilfsorganisationen
Hunger ist ja oft menschengemacht Krieg
eine der Hauptursachen das aktuell in
Ostafrika gehungert wird liegt aber auch
daran dass die Region unter der
schwersten Dürre seit über 40 Jahren
leidet verschärft wird die Lage noch
durch die ausgebliebenen
Getreidelieferungen aus der Ukraine
in Ländern wie Äthiopien Somalia Sudan
oder auch im Norden Kenias haben nach
Angaben der Weltgesundheitsorganisation
Millionen Menschen nicht ausreichend zu
essen Sandra Theis berichtet
90 Kilometer weit ist ob Lio Hassan
Salat gelaufen aus ihrem Dorf bis in
Somalias Hauptstadt Mogadischu ihren
dreijährigen Sohn Ali Osman immer auf
dem Arm hier in einem Zentrum gegen
Unterernährung bekommt sie für ihren
abgemagerten Sohn ein wenig
Flüssignahrung oblio Salat musste
zusehen wie vier ihrer Kinder
verhungerten jetzt hofft sie das Ali
Osman überlebt
ich hatte zwölf Kinder vier davon sind
durch die Dürre gestorben von den acht
die überlebt haben musste ich vier
zurücklassen sie sind krank diesem hier
ging es am schlechtesten deshalb habe
ich es mitgenommen um es zu retten
der Hunger trifft die schwächsten am
härtesten vor allem die Kinder schon
eine Durchfallerkrankung kann den Tod
bedeuten
Hilfsorganisationen warnen vor einem
Massensterben am Horn von Afrika
Millionen Kinder sind schwermangele
ernährt hunderttausende Kinder in
Somalia Äthiopien sind vom akuten
Hungertod bedroht wenn ihn nicht in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten geholfen
werden kann Grund ist die schwerste
Dürre seit Jahrzehnten viermal
hintereinander blieb es in der
regen-saison trocken der nächste Regen
kommt bestenfalls ab Oktober wenn
überhaupt ein Großteil der Hirten hat
ihr Vieh und damit ihre Lebensgrundlage
längst verloren
hinzu kommt der Krieg in der Ukraine
Somalia bezog mehr als 90% seines
Weizens aus der Ukraine und Russland
doch die Lieferwege sind blockiert die
Preise für Lebensmittel in die Höhe
geschossen das bekommen auch
Hilfsorganisationen zu spüren es fehlen
die Mittel
die Hilfe in Ostafrika gerade in Somalia
ist völlig unterfinanziert gerade von
den Freien Nationen das budgetss zu
einem Drittel finanziert das wird nicht
reichen und wenn die Geber nicht
letztendlich mehr Mittel zur Verfügung
stellen dann werden wir hunderttausende
verhungerte Kinder sehen in den nächsten
Monaten
in diesem Auffanglager gibt es nur noch
Brot und schwarzen Tee für all jene die
auf der Suche nach Nahrung ihrer
Heimatdörfer verlassen haben die Helfer
sind hilflos die Welt habe Somalia den
Rücken gekehrt
die meiste Hilfe für Somalia kam aus dem
Westen jetzt richtet sich die
Aufmerksamkeit auf die Ukraine die
Spenden gehen in die Ukraine das ist
sehr beunruhigend
das Kinderhilfswerk der Vereinten
Nationen UNICEF findet noch deutlichere
Worte
Musical if the world wenn die Welt nicht
aufhört nur auf die Ukraine zu schauen
und nicht sofort handelt wird das
kindersterben am Horn von Afrika
explosionsartig zunehmen
es ist ein Wettlauf gegen die Zeit und
mit jedem Tag wächst die Zahl derer die
es nicht schaffen
wenn sie den Menschen in Afrika helfen
wollen dass Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe hat ein Spendenkonto
eingerichtet die IBAN
de65-100 400 600 100 400 600 Stichwort
ZDF Hunger in Afrika weitere Infos auch
unter spendenpunkt zdf.de und im
zdf-text auf Seite 890
der Klimawandel wird solche Hungerkrisen
noch häufiger mit sich bringen die
Menschheit muss sich nicht nur der
Erderwärmung entgegenstellen sondern
auch Lösungen finden für eine
Landwirtschaft unter veränderten
Temperaturbedingungen dazu gehören zum
Beispiel Pflanzen die Trockenheit besser
aushalten auch in unseren Breitengraden
wird man auf Dauer wohl nicht einfach so
weitermachen können wie bisher welche
Wege die Forschung da bereits geht und
wo die Probleme liegen zeigt Christina
edelseder
Kartoffel Versuchsfeld in
niedersächsischen Landkreis Uelzen Otter
war Belana Bernina Emiliana oder Milva
hier geht es darum Sorten zu züchten und
zu erproben die besser mit den jetzigen
Klimabedingungen klarkommen eines
nämlich mag der Deutschen liebste Knolle
gar nicht zu viel Hitze wir müssen
besonders auf diese hohen Temperaturen
neue Sorten finden sonst wird das
hinterher sehr sehr schwer für die
Kartoffel anbauende Landwirte
kaum Regen und immer neue
Temperaturrekorde die vergangenen
Hitzesommer haben die Böden
ausgetrocknet bis in die untersten
Schichten und schon die nächste
Hitzewelle
der Jetstream das starke Westwind Band
der Nordhalbkugel das unser Klima
bestimmt hat sich verändert mit
dramatischen Folgen durch eine stärkere
Erwärmung der Arktis kommt es dazu dass
dieser Jetstream sich abschwächt und
dadurch Wetterlagen viel beständiger
werden als bislang bekannt und wir sehen
das genau über Europa dich Hitzewellen
viel länger
halten können und auch neue Temperaturen
Rekorde damit wahrscheinlicher werden
auch von Hugo ist froh dass es in die
Ernte wenigstens nicht verhagelt hat mit
der Hitze steigt nämlich auch die Gefahr
von extremwetterereignissen dagegen gibt
es zwar Versicherungen doch das macht
die Produktion wesentlich teurer sein
größtes Problem aber es ist zu warm zu
trocken der Weizen unser wichtigstes
Nahrungsmittel reift viel zu früh ab
vielerorts wird er schon jetzt
notgeerntet
wenn der Weizen seinen vollen Ertrag
liefern soll dann brauchen wir
Vegetation bis in den Juli hinein das
haben wir in der Regel mittlerweile
nicht mehr und deswegen haben wir
Ertragsschwankungen und auch
Ertragseinbußen bis hin zu 20 oder 30
Prozent für den Weizen zu heiß doch
insgesamt hat sich durch das wärmere
Klima die Vegetationsperiode also die
Zeit in der Pflanzen wachsen können auf
über 200 Tage verlängert
Profiteure die Gemüsebauern für die zwei
Ernten pro Jahr möglich werden bereits
die Regel sind erst der Blumenkohl wie
hier im niedersächsischen Ronnenberg
dann auf den abgeernteten Feldern noch
einmal Eisbergsalat der Boden
staubtrocken ohne Beregnung hätten die
zarten Pflänzchen keine Überlebenschance
wir haben extrem hohe beregnungskosten
also das Wasser was wir auf den Acker
Pumpen ist kein Selbstzweck wir müssen
Diesel oder Strom dafür einsetzen der
ist dass es jedem bekannt dieses Jahr
extrem teuer die Zeiten wo der Kopf
Blumenkohl mit 49 Cent im Laden lag die
wird es nicht mehr geben die Kartoffel
eins Rettung vor Hungersnot nun bedroht
von Schädlingen die der milde Winter
überleben lässt es wird daher immer
wichtiger neue Sorten zu züchten die
einerseits resistent sind gegen Pilze
Viren und Insekten andererseits der
Trockenheit besser trotzen können das
Klima wandelt die Landwirtschaft schon
jetzt
anhaltende Trockenheit erhöht ja auch
das Risiko für Waldbrände und mit den
schweren Waldbränden in Kalifornien geht
es jetzt bei Heinz weiter in einem Teil
des Yosemite Nationalparks kämpfen
Feuerwehrleute seit vier Tagen gegen die
Flammen das Feuer bedroht auch einen
Haien mit ausgewachsenen Mammutbäumen
die zu den größten der Welt gehören die
Feuerwehr konnte bisher gut ein Viertel
des Brandes löschen und versucht die
Mammutbäume mit wassersprinklern vor dem
Feuer zu schützen
zur Wirtschaft und da zum Dollar Euro
Kurs zum ersten Mal seit rund 20 Jahren
war der Euro wieder genau einen
US-Dollar wert Frank Bethmann was drückt
da so auf den Euro ja die Euroschwäche
ist zunächst mal vor allem eine
Dollarstärke das sieht man allein daran
dass der US-Dollar auch gegenüber
anderen Währungen deutlich zulegt warum
in den USA gibt es mehr Zinsen fürs Geld
ein stärkeres Wirtschaftswachstum und
vor allem eine Inflationsbekämpfung ohne
wenn und aber doch es allein auf die
Dollarstärke zu schieben wäre zu kurz
gegriffen natürlich drückt den Euro auch
die Angst dass wir hier in Europa vor
einer Rezession stehen ausgelöst durch
einen Krieg und eine Gaskrise vor der
eigenen Haustür und wie wirkt sich das
aus für uns alle ja man kann schon sagen
dieser Euro-Schwäche kommt zur Unzeit
alles ist bereits so teuer geworden und
wir erinnern uns vor allem weil die
Energiepreise ja so sprunghaft gestiegen
sind nun werden Gas und Rohöl am
Weltmarkt den Dollar abgerechnet und das
heißt für Energie müssen die deutschen
Importeure künftig mehr Euro für die
gleiche Dollar Rechnung zahlen eine
Verteuerung die sich allein aus dem
schwachen Euro Wechselkurs ergibt und
davon ist auszugehen eine die die
Importeure dann auch an die
Endverbraucher weitergeben werden
immerhin gibt es heute in Sachen
Teuerung auch eine gute Nachricht die
Preise für Rohöl sind deutlich gesunken
und lagen am Abend unter der Marke von
100 Dollar Frank Bethmann vielen Dank
der Journalist Autor und Erfinder der
ZDF-Sendung das literarische Quartett
Johannes Willms ist im Alter von 74
Jahren gestorben ab Ende der 80er Jahre
leitete er die Kultursendung Aspekte
gemeinsam mit Marcel Reich-Ranicki
konzipierte er zudem die Büchersendung
des literarische Quartett die bis heute
besteht in jüngerer Zeit trat der
Historiker vermehrt auch als Autor
hervor vor allem zur Geschichte
Frankreichs
die Deutschen hockeyspielerinnen haben
zum ersten Mal seit zwölf Jahren wieder
das Halbfinale einer Weltmeisterschaft
erreicht sie gewannen wir Viertelfinale
Spiel gegen das Team aus Neuseeland mit
1:0 den entscheidenden Treffer erzielte
Lena Michel Gegnerinnen im Halbfinale
Argentinien oder England
dieses Riesenteil hier ist James Web der
Nachfolger des berühmten
Hubble-Weltraumteleskops das war ja
schon glorreich doch das James Web
Teleskop kann noch viel mehr vor allem
kann es noch viel weiter ins Universum
blicken sein sechseinhalb Meter großer
primärspiegel ist mehr als doppelt so
breit wie der von Hubble und kann
besonders viel Licht einfangen aber auch
das Licht Spektrum ist entscheidend denn
das web-teleskop kann auch einen großen
Teil des
infrarotenspektrums erkennen also
breitere Wellenlängen die zum Beispiel
Nebel wie diesen hier durchdringen und
so können bislang unbekannte
sterneplaneten und fernste Galaxien
dahinter entdeckt und analysiert werden
US-Präsident Joe Biden hat jetzt
höchstpersönlich das erste hochglanzbild
des James webteleskops präsentiert
zeigt uns noch mehr
Galaxien tanzen einen kosmischen
angezogen von der Schwerkraft bewegen
sie sich im All und werden vielleicht
einmal miteinander verschmelzen was das
Weltraumteleskop James Web für Bilder
gesendet hat überbietet alles bisher
dagewesene auch das erfolgreichen
Vorgängers Hubble James natürlich sehr
groß und ist auch sehr kalt das ist
-33 Grad und das bedeutet dass Teleskop
gibt kein
Strahlung selbst kein Infrarotstrahlung
aus und deswegen können wir sehr sehr
mit meinem schwach Quellen im in dem
Universum sehen diese Aufnahme zeigt den
vollständigsten und schärfsten Blick
tief in die Vergangenheit des Universums
den es je gab bis kurz nach dem Urknall
und da ließe sich der amerikanische
Präsident nicht nehmen diesen
sogenannten Galaxienhaufen persönlich
vorzustellen
[Applaus]
ein neues Fenster in die Geschichte
unseres Universums und heute erhaschen
wir einen Blick auf das erste Licht das
durch dieses Fenster scheint
das ausnahmeteleskop ist nach rund 30
Jahren Entwicklungszeit vor gut sechs
Monaten ins All gestartet eine
gemeinsame Mission von NASA ESA und der
kanadischen Weltraumbehörde nun die
feierliche Vorstellung der ersten Bilder
in Amerika und Europa auch eine solch
detaillierte Ansicht der Geburtsstätte
von Sternen im Nebel ist neu erste Daten
eines Exoplaneten der also außerhalb
unseres Sonnensystems liegt deuten gar
auf Anzeichen von Wasser hin eine der
Grundlagen für mögliches leben wir
wollen ja alle wissen wie wir
hingekommen sind wir möchten wissen wie
die Erde entstanden ist wir möchten
wissen wie unser Planetensystem unser
Sonnensystem entstanden ist und dazu
müssen wir uns eben auch andere
Planetensysteme anschauen und natürlich
gibt es da immer noch die Frage gibt es
eine Erde 2.0 gibt es irgendwo einen
anderen Planeten der der Erde ähnelt und
wo es vielleicht sogar intelligente
Lebensformen geben könnte
James Web 1,5 Millionen Kilometer weit
ins All zu schicken war mehr als ein
technisches Wagnis allein dass sich das
Tennisplatz große Sonnensegel wie hier
im Test problemlos entfaltet hat ist
eine Meisterleistung
so etwas wie das Webprojekt gibt es
höchstens einmal pro Generationen
Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftlern das ist tatsächlich so
was wie die Mondlandung für die
Astrophysik James Web soll 10 bis 20
Jahre im All bleiben diese Aufnahmen
sind erst der Anfang die eigentliche
Forschung beginnt jetzt
[Musik]
und falls sie sich das Teleskop noch
einmal näher anschauen wollen können Sie
das interaktiv und in 3D in unserer
heute App
und damit verabschieden wir uns nicht
unter der Hinweis auf die nachfolgende
37 Grad Reportage heute über Nesthocker
die aus Hotel Mama nicht ausziehen
wollen und um 23 Uhr gibt es dann unser
heute schnell Update mit Nazan göttbier
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend dieses hoch bringt morgen
dem Westen und dem Südwesten
Deutschlands schon hohe Temperaturen an
die 34 Grad die Tiefs über dem Nordosten
Europas dagegen dämpfen die Temperaturen
das macht sich besonders bei diesem Tief
bemerkbar denn unter diesem tief liegen
morgen die Höchstwerte kaum über 15 Grad
davon würde man wahrscheinlich in
Spanien oder Portugal träumen denn da
geht es schwer erträgliche 45 Grad das
sind sehr große Unterschiede und die
gibt es auch bei unseren
Nachttemperaturen am Niederrhein sinken
die Werte kaum unter 19 Grad 9 Grad sind
es dagegen am Alpenrand da in
Süddeutschland ist es meist klar sonst
aber ziehen dichtere Wolkenfelder hinweg
und morgen wird es auch über
Norddeutschland noch viele Wolkenfelder
geben es ist nicht völlig ausgeschlossen
dass da auch mal ein Tropfen Regen fällt
aber sehr viel wird das in keinem Fall
werden und einen regen fällt in der
gesamten Südhälfte die
Höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen an den
Küsten von Nord- und Ostsee bei 22 bis
24 Grad sonst werden 28 bis 31 Grad
erreichen im Südwesten sind es 33 bis 34
Grad am Donnerstag wird es im Südwesten
noch etwas heißer mit bis zu 36 Grad
Richtung Thüringer Wald Franken
Oberpfälzer und Bayerischer Wald kann es
einzelne Gewitter geben wenn da mal so
fünf bis zehn Liter Regen pro
Quadratmeter zusammenkommen wäre das
schon eine ganze Menge einzelne
Regenschauer gibt es auch in
Norddeutschland Freitag und Samstag
bringen uns dann eher ruhiges
Sommerwetter bei 17 bis 30 Grad guten
Abend